why are you criticizing Jim Comey and
Andrew McCabe if a friend asked you that
question it wouldn't be hard to answer
Comey was the shifty aesthetical FBI
director in memory his deputy Andy
McCabe repeatedly lied to federal
investigators you try that you'd wind up
in jail
so why criticize these guys because they
deserve it but let's say a federal
prosecutor asked you the very same
question using this language quote what
is the reason for your continued
criticism of mr. Comey and his former
deputy Andrea G McCabe see how the tone
is different there suddenly it's ominous
it sounds more like a threat than a
question what's the point of asking that
you might wonder since when is
criticizing FBI officials a crime in
this country well apparently since
Robert Muller became a special counsel
according to New York Times that's one
of more than 40 questions Mahler plans
to ask the president under penalty of
perjury here's another one quote what
was your opinion of mr. Comey during the
transition huh your opinion whose
business is that aren't Americans
allowed to have any opinion they want
without being grilled by law enforcement
about it and then there's this question
quote what was the purpose of your July
2017 criticism of mr. sessions again
criticism of a government official
framed as a crime as if dissenting views
aren't allowed or must be justified to a
prosecutor what country is this anyway
in fact the president is allowed to have
any opinion he wants of anyone who works
for him that is true of all presidents
they get to hire and fire their own
appointees for their own reasons if you
don't like it don't vote for them this
is a democracy Trump got elected Muller
didn't presidents also get to formulate
their own policies voters can decide
whether they agree with those policies
again that's why we have elections yet
here are two more Muller questions
listen to these quote what discussions
did you have during the campaign
regarding Russian sanctions and quote
what involvement did you have concerning
2016 Republican platform changes
regarding arming Ukraine so let's review
Trump ran for office promising to
improve our relationship with Russia
he said that frequently and in public
voters heard it they agreed with him and
he
one but permanent Washington hated the
idea of getting closer to Russia they've
been pushing a war with Iran for years
that's obvious now closer ties with
Russia would make an Iran war far more
complicated Putin had to be the arch
evil and the most evil man in the world
never mind China or Mexico or other
countries whose behavior is actually
hurting the United States Russia needed
to be our enemy a country with an
economy the size of Texas that can't
make a working escalator they needed to
be evil no matter what voters said they
wanted and so that happened
the policies of Trump ran on are now
considered evidence of a crime America
is that much closer to war with Iran
mission accomplished